la situation est grave un certain nombre
de services que ça soit d'urgence ou de
réanimation sont dans des niveaux de
saturation important déjà déjà le
gouvernement at il eu raison de prendre
les mesures qu'il a prises
en tout cas ils aient eu raison de
prendre des mesures je trouve j'espère
que nous allons pouvoir en parler que
ces mesures sont en réalité toujours en
retard d'un train depuis le mois de mars
et le sujet majeur est que aujourd'hui
ce qui est désespérant c'est que notre
seule stratégie manifestement nationale
ce sont les gestes barrière or il ya
bien d'autres choses qu'il aurait fallu
faire et qu'il est peut être encore
temps de faire c'est ça le sujet moi je
comprends la réaction de certains élus
locaux pourquoi lorsqu il y a trois ou
quatre semaines le premier ministre
avait dit qu'il désormais travaillerait
avec les maires les présidents de
conseils généraux et régionaux
et là manifestement ce n'est pas le cas
moi j'ai une réunion tout à l'heure à
17h par téléphone avec le préfet des
hauts-de-seine pour soi-disant une
concertation mais en réalité on va nous
concerter sur quoi puisque tout est déjà
décidé
donc je pense que les pouvoirs publics
nationaux auraient intérêt à mieux
travailler
sané mal qu'un la une la carte et
différencier deux choses d'abord je
pense que c'est effectivement
intelligent d'avoir une carte
différencier l'homogénéité du mois de
mars étaient absurdes rétrospectivement
il faudrait pas leur faire ça va de soi
donc ça c'est bien
mais prenons la fermeture des
restaurants qui a fait couler beaucoup
de salive et d'encre depuis hier moi je
pense je m'interroge sur la pertinence
parce qu'au fond dans un restaurant vous
avez la capacité de faire respecter des
règles vous pouvez imposer aux
restaurateurs à certain nombre de règles
vous pouvez contrôler ces règles
voulaient fermer les restaurants il ya
les gens vont aller faire exactement la
même chose sans règle ailleurs et en
cela les maires et les présidents de
conseils régionaux ont raison je crois
de s'émouvoir de ne pas du tout être
écouté le sujet aujourd'hui c'est quoi
c'est que nous sommes à loos en matière
hospitalière
nous n'avons pas de marge de manoeuvre
et l'aco vide arrive en faisant déborder
le vase qui était déjà extrêmement plein
imaginez ce n'est évidemment pas
possible que nous ayons un nombre infini
de lits de réanimation et
d'hospitalisation de la question ne se
pose pas et bien dans ces cas là nous
n'aurions pas à prendre toutes ces
mesures parce qu'au fond toutes ces
mesures ne sont prises que dans un seul
but
cette faire en sorte de pas submerger le
système de santé si il n'est pas
submerger à bhl parce qu'il est
confortable
on n'a pas à prendre des mesures
contraignantes contre hancock donc
aujourd'hui on paye un système de santé
qui c'est appauvrir depuis plusieurs
jours maintenant la marée monte d'une
manière assez significative aux urgences
avec un encombrement liés en fait un
dysfonctionnement général du système de
santé sous les coups du coc vide je
m'explique
par exemple dans les hôpitaux on a fermé
les chambres à deux lits
puisqu'on ne veut pas mettre un patient
à côté d'un ensemble et logiciels ce qui
est extrêmement logique et c'est ce
qu'il fallait faire
sauf que la conséquence c'est que ça
diminue d'autant nos capacités
d'hospitalisation
donc il ya quelque chose d'un peu
contrat logique accord à comprendre
c'est que paradoxalement au mois
d'octobre nous risquons d'avoir moins de
moyens hospitaliers à la disposition des
malades du coït qu'au mois de mars par
ce coin
et oui parce qu'on a réduit nos
capacités d'hospitalisation ce qui était
bien mais voilà c'est un fait
deuxièmement c'est parce que nous allons
continuer c'est bien cet heureux de le
soigner ceux qui n'ont pas le coville au
mois de mars
on a arrêté de soigner les autres on ne
va pas refaire cette erreur et donc en
fait cela pour conséquence d'avoir moins
de moyens disponibles pour le coc vide
et c'est quand même assez incroyable que
huit mois après la crise on soit dans un
système où fond on n'a pas tiré les
leçons
on n'a pas augmenté le nombre de lits de
réanimation d'hospitalisation ont la
même réduit je trouve que c'est une
gestion qui est vraiment déplorable